early on um before the league got shut
down you know the the team had brought a
doctrine um to talk to everybody you
know tell everybody okay this is this is
happening a little bit about it and one
of the first things he said was
mass do absolutely nothing
and he
he was like i'm just letting you guys
know that um
apparently the way he phrased it was
like i guess the covet particles were so
small that they could pass through you
know you know pretty much most mass
especially cloth masks
so that that was our first thing so when
he first said that i was like okay i'm
not wearing a mask and then you have
these mask mandates and things like i'm
like what is going on and so uh so yeah
it was pretty crazy in in the bubble a
lot of things didn't make sense but we
kind of just went along with it because
we wanted to play
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
professional basketball player for the
orlando magic and author of the new book
why i stand jonathan isaac welcome to
the reuben report
what's up dave man i'm excited to be
here excited to talk to you let's go
all right let's do it this is sort of
your second time on the reuben report
because uh i was in orlando back in uh
what was it that was the end of october
and i was doing this nat con event and i
was like hey jonathan isaac's in orlando
maybe i can drag him on stage and then
you spoke in front of about 500
conservatives that was uh a little odd
for you but you pretty much brought the
house down man it was weird uh you know
first time kind of even i mean outside
of like church but like really speaking
in front of people and then it being you
know a conservative event um it was dope
though you know everybody was great i
had a great time just learning and
listening and getting a chance to talk
to you and kind of just continue to push
forward my message
so let's uh let's start off with some
basketball stuff because you know that
my dream was to be an nba player you
accomplished my dream and you're pretty
good at what i do that's what i said to
you on stage you could be doing the
talking thing for a living uh but uh but
you made it to the nba and we also have
something else in common we both have a
torn acl so that is that has taken you
out for these last two seasons is left
or right knee for you left knee
left knee for me too uh tell me a little
bit about just growing up playing hoops
did you always want to be in the nba did
you think you could make it to the nba
just the challenges there before we get
into the the book specifically
yeah i mean the book does a great job of
just telling that story of growing up in
bronx new york and playing at the rec
center in the park with my dad and and
there is when i really just kind of like
fell in love with the game not so much
scoring and all that stuff just the art
of watching guys you know do what they
do on the basketball court i was like
man it's so cool to watch them go left
to right and all these different things
but i didn't know anything about
basketball in the grand scheme of things
so nothing about college nothing about
the nba nothing about conferences
there's one story in the book where i'm
getting recruited to go to to go to
college to play ball and the coach is
saying you know do you know what
conference we're in and i'm like well
what's a conference
and i think that really speaks to how
much i didn't even think that it could
be a possibility for me to get to the
nba so it really to me is like a god
thing that i'm here because i i've never
believed in it and so yeah i mean i fell
in love with it i
pretty much put everything that i had
into it became the number one player in
the state of florida coming you know
getting out of high school to college
and then you know was a six pick to the
orlando magic
did you always have great skills or was
it kind of learned or a little bit of
both
i say all learned really you like yeah i
love to watch the guys on the on the tv
but i could never you know do anything
like that in court though the first time
i got to play on an aau team they kicked
me off the team without even telling me
and that's that's how bad i was and so
uh my ride to practice just stopped
coming uh to pick me up but um but it
was definitely learned like i got my
first coach that really was like taking
an interest in me because of my size um
was bora and he's in the book as well
and you know he was the first one to
teach me the fundamentals and develop
and and from there i kind of it was just
like riding a bike i kind of just you
know because i was watching so much and
and and you know i found that passion in
liking the way that guys move that kind
of just picked it up and kind of went
from there
were you uh were you tall immediately or
are you late spurt or what i had i had a
decent um
like like i guess like a journey of a
spurt it wasn't all that one time but i
was always you know more so the biggest
person in my class especially through
the younger years once i got to high
school i was probably six foot six one
my freshman year and then each each year
i jumped up three or four inches and
then i got to you know seven foot
who are your heroes basketball heroes
growing up who were the guys that you
were like oh man i wanna i wanna do that
i want to model it after that you know i
loved kd um you know great players still
but it's different now being able to
play against them but um but yeah i i
love the fact that he was such a a big
player but was a guard pretty much and
so him dirk pg guys that i watch all the
time and i think i watch katie before
every high school game before every
college game um yeah
and tell me about that moment you get
the uh you're at draft night and uh they
say your name and your life changes
just like that
yeah it was it was awesome but for me it
was it was it was weird because
everybody else around me seemed like
they knew what was going on like they
were ready for the moment they had you
know what they were gonna do afterwards
they're going to go party they were
going to go celebrate with their
families like everyone took it in stride
but for me it was like
like like i don't know what to do so i
kind of just after i got drafted i
walked to a pizza shop down the street
it was in new york um with my with coach
gates who's a big part of my life and uh
one of our eight my one of my agent's
assistants and we got a pizza and i went
back to the hotel room and
and sent my my parents my family home on
an uber uh and then uh went went in my
rooms it was it was kind of just like uh
it was weird i didn't know you know it
just all went by so fast as well
and it must have been pretty sweet for
you as you said you played ball in
florida then to be drafted by orlando
you get to keep it in florida and and
you seem to have a great connection with
the state yeah i i love the state of
florida and i've come to appreciate it
more and more especially as the world
has gotten crazier and crazier so um you
know i'm a fan of desantis and what he's
been able to do but um yeah i i love
florida i'm glad that i'm here i feel
like it's a god ordained thing for me to
be here from middle school till now and
uh you know i love the state
all right so let's let's pick it up
right there because you mentioned
desantis and the florida situation and
what put you on on my radar was
it's got to be almost two years ago now
pretty early on into the pandemic nba
was one of the first leagues that just
completely
shut down out of nowhere in some ways it
was it was the first big thing that did
it that then led to so many other
institutions closing down you were one
of the first guys out there that was
like hey
can we slow down with some of this or
maybe i don't want to be necessarily
injected with this thing or i'm going to
make some choices for myself etc etc so
first could you just talk a little bit
about what it was like when you were
hearing that things were going to change
and that the league was shutting down
before it got because it all didn't
happen at once that the vaccine stuff
started happening a little bit later
than that
so i think um
what happened at first was everybody was
just so afraid like right we were
getting those photos from china and some
videos and stuff like that it was like
this thing is coming to america you know
when is it gonna pop up there was cases
and then you hear that a player in the
nba has it and and you know had spread
it to his teammates and so because of
the way that it was it was portrayed in
the media it was just such a fearful
time i feel like everybody was walking
on eggshells um thinking about when when
they were going to get it and so once
the nba had shut down we had time to
kind of just not i think we went on a
quarantine really i think right around
that time um at least florida had like a
curfew it wasn't a complete um you know
lockdown but we had a curfew that you
had to be in your house and it was just
a weird time but um you know social
media wasn't a big help because of all
the things that we're spreading and
going around and so i just tried my best
to kind of take a step back and just
watch everything um there was there was
an early
hesitation with me because of the way
that things were being portrayed um it
seemed like everything was so forced and
and and and made to be fearful for
everyone to kind of be running around
like chickens with their head cuts off
so i kind of just took a step back and
said let me watch and then we get to the
bubble and then after that we get to
okay now there's a vaccine on the scene
and that's what that's the that's that's
that we get a little later
right so all right let's talk about the
bubble situation because i think people
or people that don't pay attention to
the nba that are watching us don't even
know what that is but they basically had
you guys in your own sort of lockdown so
that the season could kind of somewhat
continue and sometimes you'd have masks
on the bench but then you take them off
to play so now you're sweating on each
other and spitting on each other and
probably bleeding on each other but then
when you sit down you're wearing this i
mean none of it really made sense did
did coaches and players talk about kind
of the craziness of the whole thing
yeah we definitely did and and i think
especially early on like when we were
first getting out getting into the
bubble everyone still the the the world
is so afraid so the nba and all these
different organizations are trying to do
all that they can to kind of like okay
we need to focus on this and tackle this
but at the same time we need guys to
play so what what can we do okay they
wear the mask on the bench and they go
into the game and take it off but it was
it was such hysteria and just things
weren't making sense and and so we
definitely had conversations about you
know needing to test every day and and
the mass thing you know early on um
before the league got shut down you know
the the team had brought a doctorate um
to talk to everybody you know tell
everybody okay this is this is happening
a little bit about it and one of the
first things he said was masters do
absolutely nothing and he
he was like
i'm just letting you guys know that um
apparently the way he phrased it was
like i guess the coveted particles were
so small that they could pass through
you know you know pretty much most mass
especially cloth masks
so that that was our first thing so when
he first said that i was like okay i'm
not wearing a mask and then you have
these mask mandates and things like i'm
like what is going on and so uh so yeah
it was pretty crazy in in the bubble a
lot of things didn't make sense but we
kind of just went along with it because
we wanted to play
were you surprised the way some guys
just kind of took the orders even though
they thought it didn't work or the fact
that you guys are mostly in your mid-20s
at the peak of physical health like your
cardiovascular is better than basically
anyone on the planet you all eat right
etc etc yet everybody started doing all
this crazy stuff
i wouldn't say i was surprised i i i
mean societal pressure is is tough i
mean it it works um and especially when
you have you know people that are higher
up or um just people around you who are
who kind of adopt this mainstream you
know idea or ideology and kind of just
run with it so i i don't think i was
surprised even myself early on i was
like okay this is what we have to do it
it wasn't until things got later on and
we get out the bubble and then the
vaccine starts coming around and then i
can just see the you know just how much
it was being pushed and you have all the
people on social media you know uh
demeaning everyone and all this stuff
and then you know the thing about the
rolling stone article happens to me and
that's when i'm like okay this thing is
really not just about a vaccine it's
it's political there's an agenda there's
a bias to it and um but i know i wasn't
surprised that everybody kind of went
along with it all right so let's get to
that part in just a sec but i just want
to do a little more on the bubble so
again for people that don't know so they
basically had you guys
were you all pretty much in one hotel
and had to limit who was coming in and
out like they really the idea was that
you weren't going to basically see
anybody else you know wives kids etc and
that you would play against each other
and that was it but i've heard from some
other players that's not exactly how the
thing worked
well it was it was three hotels and so
you had teams split up in these three
hotels um and pretty much the order was
like you're not allowed to leave once
you come in that's it um as the bubble
kind of went on and we got to the
playoffs i think they allowed some
people's families to come in or just
their wives or something like that but
early on it was like strict we test
every day
i think we were testing like twice a day
i'm not even completely sure but you're
testing every day um you know they had a
lounge set up they had a barbershop for
so they tried to kind of you know help
it you know be worthwhile but it was
just it was just tough to kind of just
be in the hotel room all the time but
yeah no nothing ain't nothing out uh
food all there so it was really like a
jail loki
i mean i heard some rumors that people
were coming and going and able to get uh
lady friends inside et cetera and some
some people got in trouble you know some
people who who got caught i don't i
don't know about i didn't hear anything
about guys actually being successful
with that but i i did hear the story
about one guy trying and getting in
trouble
right so okay so then the bubble passes
and now things start shifting towards
the vaccine and that's where that video
of you
uh what month do you remember what month
that was
no not at all all right so it's a it's
about a year and a half ago i mean it
was at the height of the whole thing and
basically you you gave a spectacular you
know
we'll lay it in right here we're going
to lay in the the speech
right here so people can listen to it it
is my belief that
the vaccine status of every person
should be their own
choice um and completely up to them
without the without bullying without
being pressured without being forced
into doing so
i'm not ashamed to say that i'm
uncomfortable with taking the vaccine at
this time
i think that we're all different we all
come from different places we've all had
different experiences and hold dear to
different beliefs and uh what it is that
you do with your body when it comes to
putting medicine in there should be your
choice um free of the ridicule and the
opinion of others i've had covet
in the past and so our understanding of
antibodies of natural immunity has
changed a great deal from the onset of
the pandemic and it's still evolving um
i understand that the vaccine would um
help if if you catch covet and uh you'll
be able to have less symptoms um from
contracting it but with me having covert
in the past and having antibodies
with my current age group and a fitness
physical fitness level
it's not necessarily a fear of mine
taking the vaccine
like i said it would decrease my chances
of
having a severe reaction but it does
open me up to the albeit rare chance but
the possibility of having an adverse
reaction to the vaccine itself
um i don't believe that being
unvaccinated means infected or being
vaccinated means
uninfected you can still catch copit um
with or we're not having the vaccine
i would say honestly the the craziness
of it all in terms of not being able to
say that it should be everybody's fair
choice without being demeaned or um
talked crazy to doesn't uh
make one comfortable to do what said
person is
telling them to do
um
yeah i would say that's that's a couple
of the reasons that um you know i would
say i i'm hesitant at this time but at
the end of the day uh i don't feel that
it is um you know anyone's reason to
come out and say well this is why or
this is not why it should just be their
decision and um
you know loving your neighbors not just
loving those that that agree with you or
look like you are uh moving the same way
that you do it's it's a you know loving
those who don't
so that right there i mean you laid out
more common sense decency and thoughtful
analysis than pretty much anything
i saw on cnn and that's where i was like
man i got to talk to this guy
yeah i mean
so again like early on like me just
trying to take a step back and just see
everything that was going on i was like
okay they're saying that the the virus
has a 99.97 survival rate i'm young you
know people who are older and have
comorbidities or you know or obese are
really struggling with this thing so i
just said you know as i saw how much the
vaccine was being pushed and forced on
everybody and then you see you know
social media and people you know calling
people crazy for not wanting to take it
or even just being hesitant or asking
questions and then you have people's
medical and religious exemptions being
denied and people losing their jobs i
was like man this is insane this isn't
right and so i just said you know what
i'm young i'm healthy i don't have any
you know side effects or anything like
that i don't see the wisdom in putting
something into my body that's not going
to stop me from getting the virus or
transmitting it to someone else that's
just where i'm at and i'm not going to
do it and you know at the same time i
wanted to be a you know a hope and a
voice for other people who are going
through this who didn't have a platform
was that just a normal post-game press
conference or were you planning on doing
that or how did that even happen were
you thinking about hey i got to say
something no it was actually perfect
because the the rolling stone article so
so if
around that time the team calls me and
they say hey you know the rolling stone
wants to do an uh an interview with you
you know about everything that's going
on i'm saying cool
so i get on the phone with him and he's
like you know you're unvaccinated and
i'm thinking to myself like how do you
even know that i'm a vaccinator
welcome to the mainstream media my
friend
but but yeah it was actually a great
conversation like we're talking and like
he's like oh you know what i i i agree
with you on that you know that's a good
point and i pretty much laid out to him
exactly what i went on to say the next
day and and so but the article drops
that night like the sunday night and
it says jonathan isaac came to his you
know vaccination status whatever by
watching donald trump press conferences
and studying black history and that's
what i'm like oh my gosh everybody's on
social media calling me crazy and i i
sound i sound stupid in the article
but the next day was media day so monday
is media day and i was expecting the
question i was on the phone with my
pastor that that night and he was like
well you have an opportunity to talk
about it tomorrow immediately they have
to ask you about it and i just kind of
tried to lay it out there yeah so that
was your first time being hit by the
media like that huh welcome to the party
well it was my it was my first not being
hit by the media because then you have
the whole standing in the bubble thing
that was that was before that that was
in june of 2020 but it was the first
time right so yeah wait let's back up
tell people about that first right we we
skipped over something big
well yeah well um so
around the time of of what happened to
george floyd as tragic and as wrong as
it was there was a lot of pressure on
nba players going into the bubble um to
have to kneel for the national anthem
and where the black lives matter t-shirt
but again
same thing with the vaccine i tried to
step back and say okay what what is the
right way for me to respond in this
moment that i feel would bring real
change um and for some people in that
moment it was kneeling and wearing the
t-shirt but for me it wasn't and so i
just looked at i looked at my life and
said you know what my life has been
supported and changed by the gospel of
jesus christ and i can't i don't see a a
greater message or a greater
antidote or hope for the times that we
see ourselves in racism and not even
that just all the things that plague the
hearts of men that i know that the
gospel can change i wanted to stand up
and give that message i didn't want to
go with anybody's narrative or you know
the whole you know as crazy as the whole
black lives matter movement was i didn't
want to you know kind of just fall into
it and so i decided to be the only one
to stand and to share that message of
you know loving your neighbor um you
know the way that you want to be loved
did the team know what you were going to
do on that day when you decided to stand
and everybody else kneeled
so there's a lot of details in the book
that i explained like i called the uh i
called somebody that was in the magic
organization the night before because i
didn't want to catch them off guard so i
called them and we we had a whole team
meeting that the the day before so we
had a team meeting and the the
executives of the team you know came in
and said you know what we support you
guys on whatever you decide to do a team
had already knelt earlier that day and
so they were like you were going to give
you guys time to just talk about it as a
team so they locked they walked out and
the guys are just like yo we don't have
a choice this is what we have to do we
have to kneel we can't be the only team
that doesn't and then one of my
teammates look at me and they say yo
jonathan what are you going to do like
that kind of they kind of knew i don't
know why he's like uh what are you going
to do i said fellas i'm not going to
wear that t-shirt and i'm not going to
deal with the national anthem um and
then i i called you know somebody in the
magic organization that night and kind
of let them know and they just said okay
you know we'll handle it tomorrow
were you uh
in retrospect i mean were you thinking
man like this could cause all kinds of
problems you know i mean look what's
going on with enos canter right now the
guy's in the prime of his career he
can't get a contract i mean that that it
just creates headaches that even if you
have all the skills and everything else
the teams are just like i don't want to
deal with the headache everyone else is
going along and and that's the type of
people we want with us
look the the night before i stood um i
was on the phone with my pastor and i
was letting him know i was like yo i
don't think you understand how big this
is going to be like you know people are
getting cancelled i i didn't sign my
contract yet um i didn't sign my
contract extension so they would and the
possibility of me getting canceled then
i wouldn't have the contract that i have
right now um but yeah
i knew the backlash that was going to
come i knew you know the [ __ ] and the
uncle tom i know the you know the people
who would automatically take it in and
make it about the flag and the national
anthem and all that stuff i knew all
that stuff was going to come but at the
same time you know the one thing that my
pastor said to me is you cannot stand
for god and god not stand for you and so
i knew what i was standing for i wasn't
standing for a movement i wasn't
standing for a sign i was standing to
offer that message that we all fall
short of god's glory every single one of
us and
with anyone to throw stones you're
throwing stones from a glass house and
so um what i tried my best to do is just
kind of you know come from a humble
position and say man if if we could love
each other the way that god loves us
which is in spite of our sin in spite of
our faults then we could really change
the world
what about some of your uh your
teammates it sounds like maybe some of
them
kind of wanted to do the same but felt
the pressure and just couldn't couldn't
bear it
well at the time i i didn't know that um
and i wouldn't even say my team is per
se but i had conversations with other
guys um you know around the league and
even in other sports so after i had left
the bubble i hurt myself the next game i
tore my acl the next game and uh i got a
call from a soccer player here in
orlando and he was like hey you know i
saw what you did i want to do the same
thing but i'm terrified and this is this
is a white guy so he's he's extra
terrified
[Laughter]
and so you know i was able to talk to
you know talk him through it and
encourage him to stand up for what he
believes in um but you know it was a
very emotional moment and so i was
expecting you know guys on my team to
disagree with me i was even expecting it
to get heated and so um you know details
in the book there's a there's a team
meeting that happens the day after i
stood and it it's it's a heated
conversation between me and the guys and
uh but it pretty much ends with look you
guys know for what you believed in and i
stood for what i believed and it wasn't
a protest for you guys protest it was
just because i see the same things that
you guys see but i don't believe that
you know the black lives matter
organization or kneeling for the
national anthem i'm wearing a t-shirt is
the answer
do you uh
what's your take on just sort of how
generally sports has become so
politicized i mentioned to you when i
saw you in orlando that as a big i grew
up the biggest nba fan you can ever
imagine i mean basketball i love
basketball as much as you love
basketball
but i don't really watch anymore i just
don't watch because it became so
politicized every time i turn on an nba
game all they're doing is talking about
basketball talking about i wish they
were talking about basketball they're
talking about politics or they got the
blm logo out or they're analyzing some
race event and i'm just like man i can't
take it anymore um do are the players
talking about that too is there some
level of frustration that you guys
aren't just focused on basketball
no i i haven't had that conversation
with any players um and i i know that
it's something that you know you know a
large part of america has felt um and i
think it's just unfortunate i think
things like
uh you know organizations like the nba
or anything that's in the entertainment
um
phrase it only benefits them to be
um to be in the middle ground um but i
think because of
because of you know maybe one group or
one side being able to to to frame the
argument um and make it a moral you know
argument on a lot of the things that are
happening take the vaccine and take blm
to where if you disagree you're an evil
person and so it's easy for them to kind
of take that moral high ground and say
this is the only way this is the right
way to handle something
but um
again i think it would be in the best
interest of the nba or any organization
to just say you know this this we should
be in the middle and we should allow
people to you know to watch us and enjoy
and if an individual player wants to use
their platform to speak on something i
think that they should have the absolute
right to like like i'm doing right now
so
if anybody in league wants to stand up
and say that that was wrong or use their
individual platform that's great but i
think the i think the nba um should try
their best to kind of you know be in the
middle
i agree so all right so you so you stand
for the national anthem then you give
this incredible talk at the at the post
game on media day about the vax uh you
get some strange media reaction were you
kind of surprised where you were
welcomed and where you were kind of
shunned after that
no i i wouldn't say that i was surprised
um i i definitely you know be because
you know it was it was during the
national anthem so there's the there's a
side of the owl that is going to embrace
that and even you know the overwhelming
support of christians and everybody that
that that agree with me on that front so
i don't i wasn't surprised at all about
the the calls that i got and the
different you know media personalities
that wanted to talk to me afterwards um
i would say the only thing that i maybe
was surprised of was that maybe nobody
on the other side wanted to even have a
conversation and so uh
and and i i think just in the way that i
kind of phrased my argument or the way i
went about it i would have more people
to say you know what well let's just
talk about it you know i wasn't somebody
that was saying you know you guys are
wrong and this is terrible and i i
didn't come from that standpoint and so
i would have definitely been open to
having more conversations with the other
side but you know i went where i was
welcome and i just tried my best to
continue to to push that christ first
message
and go from there
so let's talk about the the faith part
of this because obviously you've
mentioned your faith a few times it's
it's
clearly a key part of your life uh were
you always a believer did your family
uh come from a deep religious background
so i i wasn't
i wasn't always a believer but we grew
up in church when we were young like
like
all the time we were always in church um
but then i moved from bronx new york to
naples florida and my parents split up
and uh my dad was like my hero but he
was really like the spiritual foundation
of our family um and so i went from a
predominantly black
neighborhood to a predominantly white
neighborhood and i really really
struggled with fitting in and so i tell
in the book a couple of early instances
about just how terrible that was at
getting the other kids to like me and
early on i developed the nickname
ethiopia uh because i was so skinny and
then obviously dark skin and so um i it
was the first time that i became really
self-conscious like in new york
everybody was the same it was it was fun
but once i got to naples i was like i
always tried so hard to fit in and to
kind of
work for the love of my peers that i
started to develop anxiety i started to
develop fear um and then i found
basketball and i was able to kind of put
everything in the basketball and that
brought me the people the girls that
wanted to be around me the guys i wanted
to be around me i started to make those
friends and those peers but i still
struggle with those things in the
background and so i get to florida state
i'm the number one player in the state
of florida everybody's expecting me to
be this great player that takes them to
the championship but i'm still
struggling with these things behind the
scenes and so i had anxiety attacks
while i'm on campus and i passed out in
class and all these different things and
everybody's like what what is going on
with you um and and so but for me and it
really is a wild story in the book i get
to the nba i'm living my life i'm doing
my thing and then i get injured
and i get i'm on my i'm at my apartment
and i get on the elevator and a guy
stops me and he says i can tell you how
to be great and i said tell me how to be
great i'm jonathan isaac what do you
mean
he's like you got to know jesus and i'm
like jesus man like you know i grew up
christian all this stuff yeah yeah yeah
um but from that point on like my life
really does
get flipped upside down and um i
i it it really is a story of just like
god revealing himself to me and like
these crazy coincidences and ultimately
i was able to take a step back and say
like
god loves me for me he loves me in spite
of my right and my wrong and i don't
have to work for his love and that was
the first time developing that
relationship with christ where i was
able to breathe um and kind of just let
my shoulders think like i don't have to
work for his love and i've kind of just
gone down that path of developing a
relationship with him and here in
orlando my home church jump ministries
global church and um
the story really does bring to life all
those details and those intricate
details i don't want to give too much
away because i want people to go grab
them oh we're going to link to the book
right down below don't worry about that
how has your faith uh been challenged by
the injury because it's sort of the the
nightmare of a professional athlete
you blow out the knee you blow out the
achilles etc etc i mean you're going
through that right now it's been it's
been two full seasons
yeah i mean it's it's been tough um and
it was really tough early on but i'm so
grateful that i have i i just feel like
i have the right people around me like
my pastor dr duran hepburn he's like the
the angel of the book he's a star in the
book um and me coming to faith he's
actually the one that stopped me in that
elevator and said that to me um
he's big i mean my wife is big my church
family but
it was definitely tough like you know
asking god like why do you why did you
allow that to happen like what's the
cause but now that i'm able to kind of
take a step back and see that this book
is tangible and it's alive and people
are reading it and saying how inspired
and encouraged they are there wouldn't
be a book if i didn't get injured i
wouldn't have had time to do it i
wouldn't have there wouldn't have been
really no inspiration to do it outside
of just you know wanting to write a
story about standing in the bubble but
the book is so much more than that the
book is really a journey about my life
you know overcoming fear and anxiety and
how a relationship with christ helped me
to do that and so um it really is just
pointing people to what is what i
believe is truly going to change the
world which is the love of christ and so
um i i feel that it was it was it was it
was necessary um for me to be able to
write this book
how does the faith part play into just
even being in rehab and and going
through the pain going through the
surgery all that stuff i mean i told you
my my doc wants me to have the surgery
uh obviously i'm not an nba player but
i've been prolonging this thing and i
don't really want to do it and i got prp
in my knee and it's feeling pretty good
um but just the the process because you
how long are you just laid out when you
have the uh the acl surgery just fully
in bed it was a while i think i think
for for me it was a little more
complicated than just the acl and so i
was i was in bed for
at least two months and then and then
non-weight ring um non-weight-bearing
after that for another month or so and
so on
so yeah but i think for me and the
recovery is just like
the faith thing helps me because i know
that there's a purpose behind it and so
what i've learned through the through
getting injured and being able to write
this book is like ultimately what god
happens what happens good or bad god
does have a purpose for it and there's a
verse in the bible that says all things
work together for the good to them that
love god and are called according to his
purpose so all i have to worry about is
loving god and aiming to please him with
my life and he's going to make sure that
all the good and the bad work towards my
good and so um i see that with this book
i see that you know the people leaving
the reviews and it inspiring them and i
got a message to yesterday about a guy
saying you know what i'm really gonna
pursue this faith thing and figure out
you know what a relationship with jesus
christ is because your book and so i'm
like man okay i can see the purpose in
it and so with going through rehab with
you know the day in day out monotonous
work that does get tiring and gruesome
i'm like man there's a purpose behind
all of this and i just can't wait to get
back onto the court
how do you live a life that's pretty uh
from what i could tell pretty straight
laced and i did meet your girlfriend uh
who's fantastic like
compared to what we think of say the
average nba player out there partying
all night going to strip clubs blah blah
blah how do you how do you kind of
grapple those two things like figure out
who who your crew is and all that kind
of thing
well i mean i just i guess i just try to
i just try to live my life authentically
like i i've experienced that like i'm
not one to say like you know i haven't
you know wasn't the one that was going
to the clubs and drinking and doing the
stuff i was and i got to experience and
i got to figure out that it's it's empty
man it's it's
it's it's not something that can sustain
you it's something that's you know
that's pleasurable for the moment and
then you wake up and your head is
hurting and you got to deal with you
know everything that happened the night
before and so um you know there's a
verse that says jesus came that that we
may have life and have life more
abundantly and when i was doing all
those things and living that early nba
life i really thought that i was living
and i really thought that i had the life
that everybody wanted but what i've been
able to experience in the last
four years in developing a relationship
with christ is like i wasn't even close
to living and being able to do what i do
now write a book and just see you know
my life kind of expand and i'm married
now all those different things it's like
man like it really is the truth and so
um i just try to live my live my life
and but at the same time i have the
right people around me i have
accountability um that helps keep me
strong and structured and i just kind of
keep my head down and just you know keep
moving forward
what do you want to do
when the when the nba thing wraps up
this is everything i sense i sense
something here
yeah let's listen everybody kind of you
know and almost everybody but a lot of
people say you know you need to go on
and become a pastor all these different
things but i'm always hesitant to uh to
even affirm that just because i i see
firsthand how difficult it is and how
high of a calling it is to kind of
shepherd people through life but um but
i mean i i wouldn't say no but i think
right now i'm just trying to figure out
more and more what god's plan for my
life i'm working on a second book um the
the why i stand book is being talked
about turning into a movie and so um
there's just a lot going on and i'm
excited i just want to continue to be a
a beacon of hope for people who have
struggled with anxiety and depression
and fear and let them know that there is
hope in a relationship with christ um
people struggle with suicide um and just
continue to move forward like i i want
to help um the world be a better place
and i think the message of jesus christ
is how we do that and that's just where
i'm at
by the way we should mention so daily
wire which you mentioned before they are
the publishers of the book and is is the
movie going through daily wire too are
you allowed to say uh yeah yes so it's
that they're gonna be a part of um
bringing the movie to life we're just
still kind of awesome bringing it around
to other uh to other entities so we're
figuring it out but i think it's gonna
be something that's really inspiring
really dope and you know something that
you know a family can sit down and watch
and be inspired bye
i think people got most of your message
but is there any last message i can
offer them or that you can offer them
that you want on right now
i understand i got i got the book right
here just so you guys can see it but um
yeah go go to amazon grab it again the
book is so much more than just about
standing for the bubble and and standing
in the bubble and refusing a vaccine it
really is a story about my journey and
how i got to those moments in the first
place and so um uh i believe it to be
encouraging and inspiring and even if
you don't if you even if you're not a
christian read the book and you may walk
away you may walk away one but uh but
yeah so i just want to encourage people
to go ahead and grab it it's doing great
on amazon we're going to find out uh
tomorrow or thursday you know if we made
the new york times best sellers list or
not um so we're praying that we did but
um it's just an exciting time and i you
know again just encourage people to go
grab it i hate to tell you my friend as
an old grizzled veteran of books they
should have put me at number two they
didn't put me on at all so the stats the
stats are not as honest as basketball
stats when it comes to the new york
times i've definitely heard that and so
we just we'll be i'm just my hands are
up and just saying you know what if it
happens it happened if it doesn't it
doesn't i'm excited either way about the
turnout and you know what everybody's
saying about the book new york times
basically you could have 36 12 and 8 and
they'll say you had 12 4 and 2. that's
how it works so
i got you i understand jonathan you're
awesome man uh i hope to see you soon
and i told you i got a pretty sweet
court down here in miami so with that
knees feeling good i i think here's my
prediction we're going to play horse at
some point
i think i can get i think i can get an s
on you i think i can get it as far to an
s
i can still shoot i can still shoot
oh wow an s
okay now okay we definitely got to
figure this thing out so when we play
miami next season we will we'll figure
it out all right we're gonna make it
happen it was great seeing a man the
link to the book is right down below and
uh i expect great things out of you my
friend
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell